Hallo Guten Abend, mein Name ist Yücel, ich bin der Diäusebender Arsime, ich möchte mit Ihnen das Aufnahmegeschichte schützen, ich zeige Sie damit einverstanden.
Ja, wie heißen Sie nochmal? Ich habe Ihren Namen nicht verstanden.
Ja, mein Name ist Yücel.
Ah, okay, alles klar. Ja Herr Yücel, fangen Sie.
Ja, bevor wir zu Ihren Aktuellen in Schwerden kommen, möchte ich ein paar Fragen für Ihre Person stelle. Wie heißen Sie denn?
Mein Name ist Kilian, Kilian Max.
Max ist weibische oder männliche Name?
Max ist immer ein männlicher Name.
Max ist Nachname oder?
Max ist der Vorname und Kilian. Eigentlich sind beides Vornamen, aber ich habe jetzt so gesagt, fertig.
Könnten Sie bitte das Kilian bestabieren?
Das Kilian, sagt man, ich könnte Sie bitte Kilian bestabieren, ohne das.
Okay, können Sie bitte Kilian bestabieren?
Genau, immer so sagen. K-I-L-I-A-N.
Kilian, okay.
Okay Herr Kilian, wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 45 Jahre alt.
Wann sind Sie genau geboren?
Ich bin ja auch nicht mehr.
1908?
Genau, ja, 1978.
Erste Mai 1978.
Erste Mai, okay. Darf ich fragen, wie viel Sie wiegen und wie groß Sie sind?
Ich bin 180 groß und wiege 80 Kilogramm schwer.
Was für die Saison?
Ich habe schon viele Leute gesehen, aber ich habe noch nicht angefangen.
Also, ich bin geboren.
180 groß und 80 Kilogramm schwer.
Was für die Saison?
Ich bin bewusstlos geworden.
Wann sind Sie bewusstlos geworden?
Bitte?
Ja, jetzt, deswegen bin ich gekommen.
Also, ich bin heute bewusstlos geworden.
Und dann hat man den Rettungsdienst gerufen und jetzt bin ich hier.
Okay, ungefähr wie viele Minuten vorher sind Sie bewusstlos geworden?
Wie meinen Sie das? Ungefähr wie viele Minuten vorher?
Wann sind Sie bewusstlos geworden? Wann?
Wann sind Sie?
Nicht wie viele Minuten, ist türkisch.
Wann sind Sie bewusstlos geworden?
Oder wann ungefähr um wie viele Uhr sind Sie bewusstlos geworden?
Das wollen Sie wissen, ne?
Ja, ja, ich würde gerne wissen.
Wann sind Sie?
Genau, um wann ungefähr sind Sie bewusstlos geworden?
Umgefähr die Uhrzeit.
Also, umgefähr 2 Stunden.
Ungefähr vor 2 Stunden bin ich bewusstlos geworden.
Okay, ungefähr vor 2 Stunden sind Sie bewusstlos geworden.
Haben Sie etwas bemerkt, was diesen Fall ausgelöst hat?
Ob ich etwas gemerkt habe, bevor ich bewusstlos geworden bin?
Ja.
Ob ich etwas bemerkt habe, ich weiß, was Sie meinen.
So Beispiel ist Ihnen...
Ja, ich habe Schwindel gehabt.
Schwindel.
Okay, ist Ihnen Schwarz vor Augen gewesen?
Daran kann ich mich nicht erinnern, dass es mir schwindelig war.
Und dann weiß ich nur, dass ich bewusstlos geworden bin,
dass ich aufgewacht bin.
Da war ich schon quasi lagisch schon auf dem Boden im Garten.
Ich habe vorher Gartenarbeit gemacht.
Und dann bin ich bewusstlos geworden, plötzlich.
Okay.
Haben Sie im Garten gearbeitet?
Wahrscheinlich haben Sie unter Belastung gehabt, oder?
Okay.
Haben Sie...
Ich habe keine Symptome gehabt vorher.
Ich habe...
Okay, haben Sie vor dem Anfall keine Symptome gehabt?
Schwindel.
Außer...
Mir war schwindelig, aber ich...
Außer Schwindel nicht, haben Sie nichts bemerkt.
Was meinen Sie zum Beispiel?
Ja, zum Beispiel Kopchimersen, Taupais, Käfel, Kübeln.
Nein.
Okay.
Aber Schwindel.
Ist Schwindel plöster aufgetreten?
Oder hat Schwindel zu den Menschen gesteigert?
Noch mal.
Hat sich Schwindel zunehmend aufgesteigert?
Und gesteigert.
Zunehmender aufgesteigert? Ich ist der Einste.
Zugenommen?
Oder hat sich das gesteigert mit der Zeit?
Beides zusammen kann man nicht nehmen.
Okay.
Oder man kann sagen, ist der Schwindel plötzlich aufgetreten?
Ist der Schwindel plötzlich aufgetreten?
Oder hatten Sie plötzlich schwindel?
Oder ist der Schwindel plötzlich aufgetreten?
Oder hatten Sie schon Schwindel längere Zeit und hat sich das mit der Zeit gesteigert?
So meinen Sie das, ne?
Ja, das meine ich.
Genau.
Ich habe schon lange Schwindel, ja?
Das ist nicht neu.
Seit wann haben Sie...
Immer wieder mal. Kommt und geht.
Seit wann haben Sie Schwindel?
Ich habe lange.
Ich habe das schon seit Jahren.
Seit Jahren.
Der Hausatz hat gesagt, das könnte von meiner Wirbelsäule kommen.
Okay, haben Sie Wirbelsäule Probleme?
Ja, so am Hals habe ich Probleme. Am Hals Wirbels habe ich Probleme.
Was für Bescheide haben Sie beim Halsbereich?
Jetzt nicht. Aber ich habe manchmal Schmerzen im Halsbereich.
Okay, Sie haben manchmal Nakinchemerzen.
Oder?
Ja.
Okay.
Ist Ihnen bestehende Diagnose bekannt?
Bitte?
Ich meine, als Wirbelsäule, Bandscheiben, Forfall,
oder Muskelschmerzen, oder Irgendwäsche,
krankheit, bei Ihnen bekannt?
Okay, sind bei Ihnen, an der Wirbelsäule,
bestimmte Erkrankungen bekannt, kann man sagen?
Ist an der Wirbelsäule, was bekannt ist?
An Erkrankungen, an der Wirbelsäule?
Oder man kann sagen, ist das abgeklärt worden?
Ist das schon mal abgeklärt worden, die Beschwerden an der Wirbelsäule?
Ja?
Okay.
Ist das schon mal abgeklärt worden?
Wurden damals eine Diagnose festgestellt,
möglich?
Bitte schön.
Okay, hier ist es.
Ist bei Ihnen, in welchem,
ist bei Ihnen etwas eine Wirbelsäule bekannt,
oder ist das schon mal abgeklärt worden?
Ja.
Genau.
Das ist gut.
Jetzt hör ich.
Jetzt hör ich ja.
Ja.
ist abgeklärt worden, da ist nichts bei rausgekommen.
Erinnern Sie sich daran, wie viele Minuten hat Ihre Schwindel gedauert?
Mein Schwindel oder die Bewusstlosigkeit, was meinen Sie?
Ja, zuerst meine ich Ihre Bewusstseinverlust.
Ja, also was meinen Sie jetzt?
Wie lange der Schwindel angehalten hat, haben Sie gefragt oder meinen Sie die Bewusstlosigkeit?
Ja, wie viele Minuten hat Ihre Bewusstsein-Werwusstlosigkeit gedauert?
Angehalten, wie lange hat es angehalten oder wie lange hat es gedauert?
Kann man beides sagen, egal.
Okay, meine Bewusstsein, weiß ich nicht, das kann ich Ihnen nicht sagen.
Aber...
Ist Ihnen jemand dabei?
Ich glaube ungefähr, ungefähr wohl fünf Minuten.
Fünf Minuten.
Haben Sie nach dem, nach, nach diesen Anfall muskrische Märzien oder Sukungen oder Sunggye bis bemerkt?
Danach meinen Sie?
Ja, danach, nach dem Unfall.
Nein, die vom Rettungsdienst der Not hat es auch sofort in mein Mund reingeguckt und er hat gesagt, ich habe keinen Zungen im Besten.
Und Muskelzugungen und so Muskelschmerzen hatte ich danach auch nicht.
Aber ich habe noch ein bisschen Schwindel.
Haben Sie ungewollt während dieses Anfall, ungewollt, was Sie gelassen?
Ob ich eingenäßt habe?
Ja, richtig.
Ein gelassen.
Alten ist das Makdemäck, einnässen, ne?
Ja.
Haben Sie eingenäßt?
Nein, habe ich nicht.
Eingenäßt.
Okay.
Haben Sie im Krankenwagen eine Medikamente bekommen?
Im Krankenwagen Medikamente?
Nein, Infusion.
Einfach ein bisschen.
Infusion.
Infusion, nur Infusion.
Nur Infusion, Flüchtigkeitsinfusion.
Okay.
Sie haben seit einem Jahr Schwindel.
Deswegen sind Sie schon mal beim anderen Arzt gewesen.
Ich habe, habe ich gesagt, seit einem Jahr?
Hab ich seit einem Jahr gesagt?
Ja, Sie haben seit einem Jahr Schwindel.
Aber deswegen sind Sie bei...
Länger.
Aber wissen Sie was?
Ich habe noch länger Schwindel.
Ich habe bestimmt drei Jahre schon Schwindel.
Okay.
Ich habe schon sehr lange.
Es kommt und geht.
Immer wieder mal.
Okay.
Ist die Schwindel wie Karussell, oder anderes?
Was anderes?
Für uns ist es im Karussell.
Oder Sie sind Schüttel, aber die anderen Dinge außer Umgehend
sind bei Ihnen um Rehum.
Also wie im Aufzug oder wie im Karussell?
Ja, solche ist bei Ihnen ein ganz...
Ist das noch ein Karussell?
Schwangschwindel, ne?
Schwangschwindel.
Karussell, ob sich alles dreht, oder ob es so schwankt,
das wollen Sie wissen.
Ich glaube, es ist wie so, als ob ich alles drehen würde,
wenn ich Schwindel habe.
Ich weiß es nicht genau, weil das...
weiß ich nicht.
Ich habe mich schon an den Schwindel gewöhnt,
aber ich glaube, es ist so ein Drehschwindel.
Drehschwindel, okay.
Ist Ihnen Herzkrankheit bekannt?
Ich habe keine Herzkrankheit, nein.
Ist jetzt nicht.
Oder Blutniedrigedruck?
Nein.
Nein, ich nehme keine Medikamente ein.
Okay.
Ist Ihnen keine Vorerkrankungen bekannt?
Nein.
Ich nehme keine Medikamente ein und ich habe keine Erkrankungen.
Okay, verstehe.
Okay, wie ist Ihr Appetit?
Mit dem Appetit habe ich keine Probleme.
Haben Sie in letzter Zeit Gehwisch abgenommen oder
sugenomen und gewohlt?
Nein.
Haben Sie viel Baustelle?
Okay, haben Sie höhere Störung?
Höhe Störungen?
Ja.
Nein.
Okay, haben Sie Herzfrasen oder Herzklopfen bemerkt?
Okay, haben Sie Probleme beim Wassalesen oder Stullgang?
Nein.
Okay, haben Sie...
Ich habe keine Probleme.
Haben Sie vor dem Anfall etwas gegessen oder haben Sie nichts gehabt?
Noch mal, das habe ich nicht verstanden.
Okay, haben Sie vor dem Anfall etwas gegessen?
Vor dem Anfall?
Ja.
Ich habe ganz normal gefrüchtet, wie immer.
Okay.
Haben Sie keine Hunger gehabt?
Wie meinen Sie, ich habe ganz normal gegessen, ich sage doch, ich habe Frühstück gegessen.
Okay.
Es war ja mittags, als das passiert ist.
Okay, Sie haben keine Taupas, Keppel, keine Kribbeln, haben Sie eine Lähmung,
eine Erscheinung bemerkt?
Ein Bitte, was?
Lähmung, Erscheinung.
Lähmungserscheinungen?
Ja.
Hab ich auch nicht, habe ich nie gehabt.
Okay.
Ist Ihnen eine Brutarmut bekannt?
Sehr gut, nein, auch nicht.
Also nicht bekannt, ich weiß es nicht.
Bis jetzt ist so etwas nicht bekannt.
Okay, ist Ihnen eine Allergie oder eine Verterrigkeit bemerkt?
Gehen Medikamente oder nach Rucksmitteln?
Penicillin Allergie.
Wie äußert sich diese Allergie?
Äußert, nicht äußert, mit ganz weichem Essen.
Ja, das ist so, ja, mir schwelt der Hals an und ich krieg auch Ausschlag.
Also das ist ganz schlimm, wenn ich das habe.
Okay, haben Sie noch andere Allergie oder eine Verterrigkeit?
Bitte.
Haben Sie noch andere Allergie?
Nein, Penicillin.
Okay.
Sind Sie schon mal operiert worden, Erkilian?
In der Jugend oder als Kind an den Mandeln.
Haben Sie noch andere Operationen?
Nein, nur Mandeloperation als Kind.
Okay, haben Sie belästert Haut bemerkt?
Noch mal?
Haben Sie belästert Haut bemerkt oder Hautveränderungen bemerkt?
Ach so, Sie meinen Hautausschlag?
Hautausschlag, wie rötliche Haut?
Hautrötung?
Hautrötung oder...
Also Sie meinen Veränderungen an der Haut bemerkt?
Ja, belästert Haut.
Sind Sie momentan blass oder haben Sie belästert Haut bemerkt?
Ach so, haben Sie blästert Hautblästert bemerkt?
Ach so, sind Sie blass geworden?
Verstehe ich, was Sie meinen.
Sie haben Hautblästert bemerkt?
Nein.
Nein, ich bin so wie immer, ich sehe immer so aus.
Meine Hautfarbe hat sich nicht verändert.
Okay Herr Kilian, was machen Sie beruflich?
Bitte?
Was machen Sie beruflich?
Beruflich?
Ja.
Also eigentlich bin ich von Beruf, Dachdicker.
Aber ich kann das hier in Deutschland nicht machen.
Deswegen mache ich so kleine Mini-Jobs und arbeite in Garten
und wie Gärtnerarbeit mache ich jetzt in den Gärten.
Ich bin für andere Leute.
Wissen Sie, ich kann das nicht machen mit dem Dachdicker,
weil ich so Schwindel habe, verstehen Sie?
Ja, ich verstehe Sie.
Das ist gefährlich für Sie, wenn Sie Schwindel haben.
Genau, deswegen habe ich damit aufgehört.
Wir machen jetzt mehr so Gartenarbeit.
Okay.
Aber tritt Schwindel auch bei der Gartenarbeit auf?
Ja, heute ist es aufgetreten während der Gartenarbeit.
Ich bin für die Gartenarbeit.
Darf ich fragen, wie Sie verheiratet?
Ich bin verheiratet.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Wir haben keine Kinder.
Sie haben mit Ihrer Frau zusammen?
Ja.
Okay.
Ich möchte ein paar Fragen zu Ihren Gewohnheiten stellen.
Rauchen Sie?
Ja.
Wie lange sind Sie seit wann und wie viele Zigaretten rauchen Sie täglich?
Stimmt, 30 Jahre schon.
Und wie viele Zigaretten täglich?
Andere Teilpackungen am Tag.
Andere Teil.
Trinken Sie gerne Alkohol?
Bitte?
Alkohol?
Ja, ich trinke gerne Alkohol, aber ich habe damit nicht viel.
Immer so bei Hochzeiten oder Geburtstagsfeiern,
aber immer so bei Gelegenheit.
Was denken Sie?
Alles.
Wein, Bier, Wodka, wenn es Feier gibt, trinke ich alles.
Okay.
Wann haben Sie letztes Mal Alkohol getrunken?
Lange her, ich sage doch, das ist immer bei Gelegenheit.
Ich weiß nicht, wann ich das letzte Mal auf einer Feier war.
Das ist lange her.
Okay.
Das ist nicht momentan unser Thema.
Nehmen Sie bitte die nächsten Fragen, nicht persönlich.
Das ist eine ultimative Frage.
Haben Sie Kontakt mit den Drogen gehabt?
Nein, natürlich nicht.
Ich möchte ein paar Fragen zu Ihrer Familie stellen.
Sind Ihre Eltern noch am Leben?
Ja, meine Eltern sind noch am Leben.
Sind Sie gesund oder leiden Sie an bestimmte Krankheiten?
Meine Mutter ist gesund, mein Vater hat eine Herzerkrankung.
Ich habe eine Schwester.
Ja, ich habe ein Bruder und zwei Schwestern.
Meine Schwestern, ja.
Mein Bruder ist auch herzkrank.
Ich weiß aber nicht genau, was er hat.
Okay.
Wann haben Sie das letzte Mal eher Blutdruck gemessen oder gemessen lassen?
Eigentlich messe ich niemanden Blutdruck.
Okay.
Sehen Sie manchmal Doppelbilder?
Doppel.
Doppelbilder?
Doppelbilder? Nein.
Okay.
Nein.
Haben Sie Luftnot oder Schwertmung?
Luftnot habe ich auch nicht.
Haben Sie Brustschmerzen?
Eigentlich nicht, aber heute, nachdem ich bewusstlos geworden bin,
habe ich jetzt auch leichte Brustschmerzen.
Also ich habe das Gefühl, hier drückt etwas auf meiner Brust.
Nein, ich habe das Gefühl, da sitzt einer drauf auf meiner Brust.
Wie eine Ende gefülle oder drückt gefülle.
Ja, genau. Leicht. Ja, so.
Irgendwas ist nicht in Ordnung.
Haben Sie Todesangst?
Nein.
Haben Sie Bauchschmerzen?
Ach Schmerzen? Nein.
Bauchschmerzen, ja.
Nein.
Okay.
Haben Sie Ornenschmerzen?
Ornenschmerzen?
Ja.
Okay.
Ja, ich bin fertig mit meinen Fragen.
Wollen Sie etwas hinzufügen, oder?
Haben Sie Fragen?
Ich hätte gerne gewusst, was es ist,
weil ich habe schon lange schwindelt,
aber ich bin noch nie bewusstlos geworden.
Vielleicht können Sie mir sagen, was ich habe.
Ja, schwindeln ist eine schwierige Symptom.
Schwingten.
Nicht symtom, zymtom.
Was ich machen muss,
ist, dass wir noch ein paar權en Diagnos predicted sind.
Und das behave demmotionär,
dass wir eine italienische professorale
Neurologische Unterzucht und dann werde ich ein paar Bilkebändes verfahren, veranlasen.
Ich möchte bei Ihnen auch Blut abnehmen, um einige Krankheiten auszuschließen.
Bei der Blutbild möchte ich ein kleines, bei der Blutabnahme...
Können Sie nachher bei der Vorstellung sagen?
Also ich muss jetzt bleiben oder darf ich nach Hause gehen?
Ja, Sie müssen bei uns bleiben, weil wir wollen, dass wir alle Ergebnisse bekommen.
Okay, alles klar. Bin ich mit einem Verstanden.
Haben Kollegen andere Fragen?
Fragen? Ich hör zu.
Wie oft kommt es zu einer Schwinderlika-Tage?
Ja, gute Frage. Wie oft und wie lange dauert es?
Wie lange dauert es?
Wie oft?
Sehr gut. Das ist unterschiedlich.
Also Schwindel kommt immer wieder mal, habe ich oft?
Wie soll ich Ihnen das sagen?
Wie lange dauert es?
Das kommt so jeden Tag mal und das dauert immer so fünf Minuten an.
Manchmal auch länger. Manchmal habe ich mehrmals am Tag, manche Tage habe ich gar keinen Schwindel.
Es ist unterschiedlich.
Haben Sie gegenseitig etwas eingenommen?
Nein, ich habe nichts eingenommen.
Haben Sie etwas bemerkt, was sich Winderl verbessert oder versteht hat?
Ehrlich gesagt nicht, weil der Schwindel war eigentlich nicht so strahlend. Es war immer so ein leichter Schwindel.
Das hat mich jetzt nicht so gestört. Ich habe zwar immer wieder Schwindel, aber es war nicht so ausgeprägt wie heute.
Heute habe ich Angst gekriegt, weil ich bewusstlos geworden bin.
Sonst habe ich immer nur wenige, also leichten Schwindel.
Ich habe nichts genommen.
Der Haus hat einen Langzeit-EKG gemacht und das Langzeit-EKG war in Ordnung.
Wie lange dauert Ihre Gartenarbeit heute?
Was bedeutet, wie lange dauert Ihre Gartenarbeit?
Wie lange hat Ihre Gartenarbeit gedauert?
Wie lange dauert Ihre Gartenarbeit?
Ich arbeite noch.
Ich habe angefangen zu arbeiten.
Ich habe bestimmt 30 Minuten, 45 Minuten gearbeitet.
Dann kam der Schwindel, dann wurde er richtig stark und dann bin ich bewusstlos geworden.
Es gibt bestimmte Auslöser für den Schwindel.
Nein, im Alltag ist mir das nicht aufgefallen, dass irgendwas das auslöst.
Ich meine, haben Sie bemerkt, ob es eine bestimmte Bewegung durchführen kann?
Nein, mit Bewegung hat das nichts zu tun.
Schwitzen Sie bei dem Schwindel?
Nein, eigentlich nicht.
Wenn ich Ihnen Schwindel übergeben muss, dann muss ich mich noch nie übergeben.
Haben Sie Ihren Blutdruck Regal-Music gemessen?
Nein, habe ich ihm ja auch schon gesagt.
Ich habe eigentlich noch niemanden Blutdruck gemessen.
Wenn ich mal beim Hausarzt war, der hat dann mal Blutdruck gemessen, aber ist auch selten.
Dann war der Blutdruck aber in Ordnung.
Okay.
Der Patient hat gesagt, dass sie keine Hörstörung haben.
Also in meinen Ohrgeräusche?
Ahrensausengeräusche? Nein, habe ich nicht.
Ich höre dejar ganz gut.
Wirklich nicht. Ich habe Schwindel, ja.
Und heute bin ich das erste Mal bewusstlos geworden und heute hatte ich auch das erste Mal,
und ich habe immer noch so ein bisschen Druck auf der Brust.
Wann haben Sie Ihre Untersuchungen allgemein machen lassen?
Sie meinen das mit der Halswirbelsäule?
Nein, nicht nur mit der Halswirbelsäule.
Es ist nicht viel gemacht worden, ehrlich gesagt.
Ehrlich gesagt ist nur an der Halswirbelsäule ein Röntgen gemacht worden und ein Langzeitekg.
Das war vor ungefähr drei Monaten.
Ich weiß nicht, was er alles gemacht hat, aber er hat gesagt, das Cholesterin war wohl erhöht, aber alles andere waren in Ordnung.
Ich weiß aber nicht, wie hoch mein Cholesterin war.
Noch eine Frage von dem Kollegen.
Er ist ein Ersatzgeber.
Hallo, ich bin der Herr.
Ich habe einen neuen Patient aufgenommen.
Ich möchte Ihnen das mal vorstellen.
Ja bitte.
Herr Kilian Max ist ein 45-Jähriger Patient,
der sich bei uns notfallmäßig nach einem bewusst sein Verlust vorstellt.
Das Sankop ist nach einem garten Arbeit.
Sankop ist ein türkischer Begriff.
Sankop gibt es nicht.
Sankop.
Nicht Sankop, Sankop.
Sankop ist nach einem garten Arbeit aufgetreten.
Seit einem Jahr ist das Ersatzgeber.
Ersatzgeber, nicht Ersatzgeber.
Ersatzgeber.
Ich habe gesagt, schon seit drei Jahren.
Er berichtete das seit drei Jahren Schwindelhabe.
Diese Schwindel sei Drehschwindel.
Es dauert fünf Minuten.
Es dauert laut Patient immer ca. fünf Minuten.
Er berichtete das seit drei Jahren Schwindelhabe.
Seine Schwindel übt er seine Beruflich aus.
Er arbeitet momentan ein Gartenarbeiter.
Er ist ein Ferragat und lebt mit seiner Frau zusammen.
Er ist ein Raucher.
Seit 2 Jahren ist er ein anderes Halbpackungssigaretin.
Was 40 Packers entspricht?
35 Jahre eine Teil Packungen.
Er hat mehr als ein Alkohol und Drohung gefehlt.
und röntgen im Halsbereich und Blutabnahme unaufwählig gewesen sein.
Sehr gut gewesen sein. Aber röntgen nicht im Halsbereich, sondern dann weiß man nicht,
weil es im HWS Bereich ist.
Ja, vor diesem Anfall habe ich 30 oder 45 Minuten im Garten gearbeitet.
Und danach habe ich erst einmal ihr bewusst sein verloren.
Nicht ihr, sondern als ein Mann.
Ja, richtig.
Nach dem Gartenarbeits habe ich erst einmal sein bewusst verloren.
Und ich habe auch das Gefühl, dass bei ihm erst einmal ein enges Gefühl im Brust aufgetreten sei.
Die Brust in der Brust oder auf der Brust aufgetreten ist.
Nicht der Brust, sondern der Brust.
Und es ist auch nicht nach dem Gartenarbeits, sondern nach der Gartenarbeits, weil es ist die Gartenarbeits.
Okay.
Ja, nach der Gartenarbeits.
Zwei bei ihm erst einmal ein bewusstes Verlust aufgetreten und erst einmal ein enges Gefühl aufgetreten.
Ich habe das Gefühl, dass ich das Verlust aufgetreten habe.
Die pharaxischen Diagnostik ist unvergesslich, dass ich meine Positionale vertreten habe.
Was haben Sie gesagt? Das habe ich nicht verstanden.
Ich meine die Pharaxischen Diagnostik.
Nein, so heißt das nicht im Deutschen.
Das ist Türkisch.
Das ist aber nicht Türkisch, das ist Deutsch.
Das ist wahrscheinlich Pharaxischen Diagnostik.
Das ist meine Sicht.
Ja, ich meine.
Das ist eine Art der Pharaxischen Diagnostik.
Was noch?
Sie meinen den Pharaxischen Diagnostik, ich weiß das nicht.
Sie meinen den Pharaxischen Diagnostik, den ich in der Lage habe.
Ja, in der Lage habe ich mich verstanden.
Den Pharaxischen Diagnostik, den ich in der Lage habe.
Das ist, wenn die Kristalle nicht in Ordnung sind.
Sie haben gesagt, es könnte sein, dass das etwas mit den Karotiden zu tun hat.
Ja, ein Karotidsystem könnte sein.
Was noch?
Haben Sie den Patienten, wenn Sie Ihre Hauptdiagnose haben,
Sie haben gesagt, es ist Arytmie.
Wenn Sie denken, dass die Hauptdiagnose an der Arytmie ist,
Sie haben mich kein einziges Mal gefragt, ob ich Herzrasen hatte.
Ob ich Herzstolpern gespürt habe.
Ich habe dir gefragt, Sie haben nicht gefragt, ob ich Herzrasen habe
oder ob ich Herzstolpern habe.
Ja, ich habe das.
Hat er?
Ja, wahrscheinlich wegen dieser fervenden Probleme konnte ich sie nicht.
Nein, Mehmet, der Patient hat gesagt,
Ihre Hauses, seine Hauses, einmal Langzeit-AKG.
Nein, nein, er hat aber auch nicht gefragt,
Herr Mehmet, Herr Yücel hat aber auch nicht gefragt,
ob ich Herzrasen habe.
Nein, nein, er hat aber auch nicht gefragt,
Ja, er hat gebraten.
Er hat gebraten.
Haben Sie? Was habe ich gesagt?
Wegen zeitwündung Probleme war wahrscheinlich,
haben Sie nicht gehofft.
Was habe ich gesagt? Was habe ich geantwortet?
Ich habe keine Herzrasen.
Und wieso denken Sie, dass das eine Arytmie ist?
Ja, Sie haben einen Gefühle und eine Senkope.
Und schwindelig, ich dachte, die Arytmie ist alles gut.
Also wir verdachten Diagnose ab wie?
Differenzial Diagnose ist Schwindel,
wenig Nalagerungsschwindel,
oder Karottesproblem, Karott-Stinnose.
Was noch?
Ja, Herzunsuficient.
Nein.
Wenn ich eine Herzunsuficient habe,
habe ich Luftnoten.
Nein, nein.
Wenn ich eine Herzunsuficient habe, habe ich Luftnoten.
Und ich habe Unterschenkel-Ödeme.
Haben Sie mich nach Ödemen gefragt? Nein.
Also die Differenzialdiagnose kann man leicht ausschließen.
Haben Sie Unterschenkel-Ödeme
und haben Sie Luftnoten bei Belastung?
Und ich habe gesagt, nein, ich habe nie Luftnoten.
Ich habe keine Luftnoten.
Ja, Sie haben keine Luftnoten.
Also Herzunsuficient unwahrscheinlich.
Was noch?
Ich meine, er sagt, dass er Druck auf der Brust hat.
Ja.
Was ist die häufigste Diagnose als Erste,
woran man denken muss,
was man immer ausschließen muss,
wenn ein Patient bewusstlos wird
und Druck auf der Brust hat? Was kann es sein?
Ja, wir müssen mir auch gleich
die Frage des... Ja, natürlich.
Natürlich, natürlich.
Natürlich, natürlich. Hat er aber nicht.
Müssen Sie aber ausschließen,
das müssen Sie sagen, wenn ein jeder Patient,
der bei uns auf die CPU kommt,
auf die Chestpain unit, jeder Patient,
der bei uns auf die CPU kommt, mit Syncope.
Die kriegen alle Herzenszyme.
Jede Syncope
kriegt Herzenszyme abgenommen, immer.
Und 12-Kanallika geht.
Weil wir wissen ja nicht, ob der asymptomatisch
trotzdem
Stummeninfarkt hat. Also das geht nicht.
Und er hat ja Beschwerden.
Also, Myocardinfarkt
müssen Sie auf jeden Fall als der Pferdenzialdiagnose
erwähnen. Was noch?
Was müssen Sie noch erwähnen?
Wenn ein Patient bewusstlos wird
und sich das Schmiel hat
und dann jetzt Brustschmerzen hat.
Welche Differenzialdiagnose müssen Sie erwähnen?
Aus dem Myocardinfarkt.
Aus Tendose.
Bitte? Aus Tendose.
Aus Tendose. Aus Tendose.
Sehr gut.
Ja, richtig.
Aus Tendose kann es sein.
Sehr gut.
Schwindel ist ja so. Dann hat man Schwindel.
Er ist halt ein junger Patient.
Dann würde halt eine rheumatische Ursache infrage kommen.
Das ist eine gute Differenzialdiagnose.
Die ist ja auch eine gute Differenzialdiagnose.
Typisch Schwindel, Sönkope und Brustschmerz.
Alle Trias.
Typisch Trias für auch eine Klapenschnenose.
Schwindel, Sönkope, Brustschmerz.
Super.
Myocardinfarkt.
Superdifferenzialdiagnose.
Was noch?
Einer, der bewusstlos wird,
Schwindel hat und Schmerzen auf der Brust hat.
Was ist noch eine sehr,
sehr gefährliche Diagnose, die man ausschließen muss?
Superdifferenzialdiagnose.
Das sind ja eher so.
Aber Kooperative, keine Kooperative.
Ja.
Ausbisschokonfektion.
Natürlich immer eine Art.
Ausbisschokonfektion ausschließt.
Aber das ist die Beug,
das ist die Dritte.
Nein, aber er hat ja ein bisschen Schmerzen trotzdem. Er hat Schmerzen auf der Brust, er hat Druckgefühl.
Muss man trotzdem ausschließen, geht nicht anders.
Muss man erwähnen in der Prüfung als Prenzialdiagnose? Wenn einer eine Synkope hat, Schwindel hat,
muss man das auch als Prenzialdiagnose. Ich möchte eine Art Antisektion ausschließen.
Ich muss als erstes einen Myokardinfarkt ausschließen. Das sind die wichtigsten Sachen.
Ich muss eine einfache Sache, die man ausschließt. Und dann kommen die neurologischen Sachen.
Paroxysmalabenecnalarischwenn, das sind ja die harmlosen. Das ist ja nicht schlimm, wenn man das mal übersieht.
Aber wenn sie eine Art Antisektion übersehen, stirbt der Patient.
Ortenklappensthenose stirbt er auch nicht sofort, aber Myokardinfarkt kann er auch sterben.
Und diese Sachen müssen auch geschlossen werden, Myokardinfarkt und Ortenklappendisektion.
Was kann er noch haben? Was kann es noch sein? Was müssen wir noch ausschließen?
Wenn einer Schwindel hat, Synkope und Schmerzen, Lungenembolie, das ist auch tödlich.
Das müssen sie auch ausschließen. Wir wissen es ja nicht, kann ja sein.
Das sind die wichtigsten Sachen, die man ausschließen muss.
Lungenembolie, Ortenklappendisektion, Myokardinfarkt.
Dann kann man in Ruhe Herzultraschall machen, gucken, ob der eine Ortenklappensthenose hat.
Daran wird er nicht sofort sterben. Der ist jetzt im Krankenhaus.
Aber die anderen Sachen müssen sofort ausgeschlossen werden.
Und der Paroxysmalabenecnalarischwenn kann sein, dass er das hat.
Aber das ist total harmlos. Das ist so harmlos, da macht man ein paar Bewegungen
und dann ist alles wieder in Ordnung. Verstehen Sie, was ich meine?
Das muss man als Differenzialdiagnose auch erwähnen.
Das heißt, bei diesem Patient eine Diagnose zu stellen ist sehr schwierig.
Deswegen müssen Sie sagen, Synkope, Schwindel, Brustschmerz,
da kommen ganz viele Diagnosen infrage.
Ich kann jetzt nicht genau sagen, was der Patient hat, aber so würde ich das dann der Prüfung.
Da kommen sehr viele Diagnosen infrage, aber ich würde erst mal mit den wichtigsten anfangen
und mich langsam abarbeiten.
Das heißt, ich würde erst mal gucken, EKG und Labor, ob der N-Milkartinfarkt hat.
Anemie war auch sehr gut. Aber das haben Sie auch schnell ausgeschlossen,
wenn Sie Labor machen. Das können Sie auch sagen.
Das war wirklich auch sehr gut.
Und da können Sie auch noch eine Frage stellen, wenn Sie das Gefühl haben,
Sie haben nicht gefragt, ob ich habe gewartet, ob ich Terrestuhl habe,
ob ich schwarzen Stuhlgang habe, ob ich Mutimstuhl habe.
Hätten Sie sich schnell ausschließen können?
Ich habe der Prüfer gesagt, der ist gut, der weiß, der Diagnose abgequert.
Also, ich weiß nicht, was der Patient hat.
Der Patient könnte viele Sachen haben, weil diese Symptome sind sehr breit, die Diagnosen.
Ich würde erst mal das wichtigste ausschließen, Milkartinfarkt, Troponin, CK, CKMB, EKG. Stimmt es?
Stimmt aber, ich denke erst mal, ich denke...
Was machen Sie noch im Labor, um Lungenembuli und Ortendissektion auszuschließen?
Welchen Wert müssen Sie im Labor machen noch?
Dedimer.
Bitte?
Sehr gut. Super. Genau die Dedimerer, ein Wert.
Und mit dem können Sie die Ortendissektion ungefähr.
Kann man nicht sicher, aber eine Lungenembuli können Sie sich ausschließen,
wenn es normal ist.
Das heißt, wir machen die Dedimerer, wir machen die Herz und Züme.
Und das EKG natürlich.
Somit haben Sie mit diesen Sachen schon sehr viel ausgeschlossen.
Wie lange ist es?
Und danach können Sie natürlich in Ruhe was machen.
Was machen Sie an Untersuchung?
Herz-Ultrischer Untersuchung.
Sehr gut. Was für eine Ultraschall?
Doppler Sonografie und Eco-Cardiografie.
Sehr gut. Genau.
Und das ist auch der Patient Pumpstörungen hat, ob er ihn infarkt hat,
ob er eine Herzinsuffizienz hat.
Herz-Klöpfen.
Genau. Die Ortenklappenschein-Use sieht man super.
Sie sieht man nur im Echo. Sehr gut.
Das haben Sie dann auch gemacht und Sie können auch mal auf die Karotiden
dann gucken mit dem Schalke.
Alles erledigt, fertig. Punkt aus.
Jetzt sage ich Ihnen, was der Patient hat.
Der Patient hat erhöhte Stroponien.
CK, CK, MB ist normal.
Dieser Fall stimmt, was ich Ihnen erzähle.
Der hat bei mir auf der Station gelegen.
Das ist wahr. Das ist nicht gelogen.
Ist nicht erfunden. Das ist eine wahre Geschichte.
Der Name ist anders nur.
Alter und alles richtig.
Dieser Patient hat nur Troponienerhöhung, leicht,
keine CK und die DDR ist auch erhöht.
Was würden Sie bei einem 45-Jährigen, der synkopiert ist,
ein unauffälliges EKG hat, echokardiografisch,
das haben wir noch nicht gemacht.
Wir haben das Troponien gesehen.
EKG?
Ein bisschen Senkung, V5, V6.
Ich würde gerne Pomegranamol auszuschliessen.
CT, ja.
Die, die mehr Rachen Sie gemacht haben, ist erhöht.
Sie machen aber zuerst, Sie machen aber zuerst.
Wir haben aber zuerst, weil wir die DDR, die mehrere,
nicht von Anfang an mitgemacht hatten.
Das lag bei einer anderen, bei einer anderen Kollegin,
dieser Patient.
Ich erzähle das nur, weil er danach zu mir gekommen ist, zur CPO.
Vorher war er auch noch mal Station.
Da ist eine Katheteruntersuchung gemacht worden,
weil es Troponien das erste bei 13 war
und das zweite Troponien angestiegen ist,
das ist auf 36.
Troponien ist angestiegen.
Also haben die eine Herz-Katheter-Untersuchung gemacht.
Ja, ja.
Okay. Herz-Katheter-Untersuchung.
Ein Gefäß ist verengt.
Die haben das Gefäß aufgemacht.
Würden Sie bei den Patienten, die DDR, die mehr Röhrhöhe,
trotzdem ein CT machen?
Ja.
Sehr gut, genau.
Aber vorher sage ich Ihnen noch etwas.
Danach haben wir ein Echo gemacht
und wissen Sie, was wir im Echo gesehen haben?
Die Aortenwurzel, wissen Sie, ne?
Genau am Herzen.
Nur die Wurzel, noch nicht Auszendenz. Vorher.
Wurzel, dann kommt die Auszendenz.
Die Wurzel war 58 Millimeter.
Ist das viel?
Nicht viel, aber größer.
58 Millimeter Aortenwurzel?
58 Millimeter, nicht operativ, aber größer.
Also ab 55 Millimeter bei symptomatischen Patienten,
ist das eine Notfallindikation für eine Operation?
5 und?
Ab 55 Millimeter.
Aortenwurzel, ab 55 Millimeter.
Elisikis.
Elisikis runterkehr.
Sonder haben wir ein Dingens gemacht.
Und im CT hatte er 61 Millimeter.
Ist das viel?
Nein, ich habe viele Patienten gesehen
und 58 Millimeter lange ja.
Aber okay, aber asymptomatisch, ne?
Aber der ist symptomatisch.
Der ist bewusstlos geworden und hat Druck auf der Brust.
Ich denke, diese Patienten
werden erst mal kardiologisch unbedingt Sinkopee benken.
Wir haben einen CT gemacht und im CT hat er keine Dissektion.
Also schon mal gut, ne?
Die Dissektion ist ausgeschlossen.
Aber Aortenwurzel ist bei 61 Millimeter.
Und bei Patienten, die symptomatisch sind,
das ist aber egal, das ist zu speziell.
Das müssen Sie nicht wissen.
Also Musste haben wir wieder.
Herzchirurgie, Herzchirurgie, Herzchirurgie haben wir vorgestellt.
Was geht mit Aortenwurzel?
Genau.
Und die Aortenklappe, nämlich,
weil warum die Aortenwurzel war ja bei 61,
der hatte auch eine hochgrade Aortenklappe insuffizient.
Ja, okay.
Hatte wirklich, also der ist 45 Jahre alt, ne?
Und der hatte, die Aortenwurzel war bei 61 Millimeter.
Und weil die Aortenwurzel so weit ist,
hatte er auch eine Aortenklappe insuffizient.
Und zwar eine hochgrade Aortenklappe insuffizient.
Das hat man im Echo dann gesehen.
Das habe ich extra nicht gesagt, weil wenn ich das sage,
dann wissen Sie sofort, was der Patient hat.
Okay, Herzchirurgie.
Ich habe eine Frage.
Als differenzial der Diagnose der Akademie
sagen transistorische ischemische Attacke oder Apoplexy?
Natürlich kann man auch nicht ausschließen, ne?
Der hat Schwindel.
Manche Patienten kommen einfach nur mit Schwindel und Sympcope.
Aber ihm nicht passt, ist der Druck auf der Brust, ne?
Das passt nicht.
Also trotzdem kann er natürlich, wir sagen im Deutschen,
Leuse und Flöhe haben.
Das bedeutet, perrehenbidolabile.
Das heißt, er kann Apoplexy und Herzinfarkt haben.
Natürlich, kann auch sein, ne?
Also deswegen muss er natürlich trotzdem,
wenn das jetzt mit der Aortenklappe nicht festgestellt werden könnte,
also wurde, wenn wir das nicht gewusst hätten,
hätte man natürlich auch noch einen CT vom Kopf gemacht, ne?
Okay, danke.
Also wir haben das so gemacht.
Wir haben den Patienten am Innerhalb von einer Woche, also wir haben,
nach fünf Tagen haben sie den Patienten sofort übernommen.
Wir haben den bei uns am Monitor gelassen.
Der musste Monitor überwacht werden noch.
Und dann haben wir ihn mit Krankenwagen in die Herzchirurgie,
der ist dann operiert worden.
Eigentlich müssen sie nicht wissen,
dass eine Aortenwurzel das nicht.
Aber vielleicht können die sich fragen,
wie teilt mein Aorten die Sektion ein?
Wissen Sie das?
Ja.
Wie?
Eko-Kardiografie.
Nein, Standford A, Standford B.
Nein, ja.
Ich kenne nichts.
Aber ich glaube, das müssen Sie nicht wissen, ne?
Müssen wir das wissen, ne?
Müssen wir nicht, ja.
Ja, das müssen Sie nicht wissen.
Das ist zu speziell, ne?
Sie müssen nur wissen, den Differenzialdiagnostik
könnte eine Ordnungsdissektion in Frage kommen.
Machen welche Diagnostik ist das allerbeste,
haben Sie schon gesagt, CT-Angiografie, ne?
Goldstandard.
Goldstandard ist immer noch CT-Angiografie.
Was kann man im Echokardiogramm schnell sehen?
Pericarderguss.
Ob Wasser im Herzbeutel ist, warum sieht man das?
Weil es blutet da ein, ne?
Weil wenn das im Ascendance-Bereich, Wurzelbereich ist,
dann kann das in den Pericard einbluten.
Muss nicht, 30% blutet in den Pericardbeutel ein.
Dann können Sie sehen, wenn man das bei Patienten sieht,
haben die Glück gehabt.
Dann hat man ganz schnell die Dissektion gesehen, ne?
Da macht man CT und dann weiß man, was der Patient hat.
Aber nicht alle haben einen Pericarderguss.
Goldstandard ist und bleibt CT-Angiografie.
Und was muss man machen, wenn der Patient die Dissektion hat?
Wie muss der Blutdruck sein?
Unter 100, 120.
200?
120?
Ja, unter 120.
Der Blutdruck muss unter 110 sein, systolisch.
Warum?
Das ist Hypotonie.
Wie wollen wir so haben, damit es nicht weiterblutet?
Und welches Medikament ist Mittel der Wahl bei Patienten,
damit der Blutdruck so niedrig gehalten wird?
Auch bei Ortenanorismen, wenn wir über 60 sind.
Beta-Blocker.
Ja, Beta-Blocker.
Marmut Hoja, Beta-Blocker bei Ihnen auch?
Ja, auch.
Beta-Blocker, Mittel der Therapie ist Beta-Blocker.
Aber das ist egal.
Ich wollte nur, das sind so wieder so,
Entschuldigung, das ist wieder etwas kompliziert,
das, was ich vorgestellt habe,
aber solche Patienten kommen wirklich, die kommen in die Klinik.
Ja, und die sind bewusstlos geworden.
Die haben Schwindel und ganz leichte Brustschmerzen.
Manche haben keine Brustschmerzen,
aber sie müssen trotzdem sagen,
ich weiß nicht, was der Patient natürlich genauer Diagnose kann,
ich kann nicht sagen, aber ich kann vermuten,
so und so und so und so, ich schließe das aus
und schließe etwas aus.
Aus einer 5-Burnier-Pranose ist das ja dann ja.